and then Shepherd pics red green or blue
and then like the same thing happens
regardless the Reapers are gone or dead
or whatever sorry what does puzzle do
you have to do with all this ah he
punches the reporter in the face I'm
pretty sure that was commander shepard
as long as there's more punching in the
next Mass Effect I don't care well at
least I've dared to dream a little
bigger as the series went on the RPG
elements of Mass Effect got more relaxed
I'm not saying that's a bad thing
because the action was more fluid and
the conversation systems got a big boost
from the interrupt you want some oh and
even though there were weapon mods in
Mass Effect 3 you know what I miss
fiddling around in menus equipping
different ammo types that weren't powers
a while I like the action I also really
like the nitty-gritty menu trawling so
no oversimplified RPG elements Lee's
garrus we had something special but what
would the next Mass Effect having a new
protagonist and everything I think it's
time for both of us to move on I'm happy
with the clean slate new characters and
locations and whatever when romance
herbal characters come back there's a
disconnect like when Alistair cami Odin
dragon age inquisition my Inquisitor
didn't have any knowledge of this guy so
I was freaking out and wanted this great
big reunion all I got was this man who
seemed like a bit of a jerk and it kind
of sucked you seem way to invest it I am
so I'll take a mention but don't bring
them back back regardless of which
ending / color palette you chose at the
end of mass effect 3 the Reaper threat
is gone done and dusted they're all
scrap metal now so they're out it's over
I can't come back or else they'll become
the Daleks of mass effect so unable to
climb stairs basically an overused enemy
that started off as scary but got boring
due to overkill hun most definitely
intended now I didn't mind the Mako so
much because it offered this great fake
sense of freedom it dropped you into
these wide open spaces but they weren't
really populated with anything even if
you found a collectible you probably
wouldn't be able to unlock it electronic
skill is too low the next Mass Effect's
Mako looks pretty nifty look at her take
that corner but if
gonna use it to explore world give us
something to actually explore other than
coming up against the occasional
thresher more and please make it handle
better dear God Bioware make it handle
better why didn't he just take tally on
the miko she's like a tech moon wizard a
moon was it really that's the dumbest
thing I've ever heard okay this isn't
dragon age anyway what would you like to
see Mako return to Mass Effect what
should we left behind in the space dust
let us know in the comments section
below and we'll see you next week what
you're all I know
but when is Bruce Bruce Wayne okay where
does Bruce alt